this is highs and lows we flew a private
jet back okay so shifty is 20 years old
and he's in a private jet he was working
at Home Depot before right organizing
Mexicans outside and now he's in a
private jet we get back he takes an Uber
to his home gets out the Uber phone
falls out car runs over it destroys it
he can't call another Uber or anything
to go to the Apple store to get it fixed
walks to the subway Subways are down
takes the bus into the city realizes
that he hasn't taken a [__] yet he's
about a hundred feet from the Apple
Store shits his pants okay holy shits
his pants goes into the Apple store with
full [__] in his pants buys a new phone
doesn't call an Uber to go home like he
should gets back on the subway with [__]
pants with [__] pants and I'm like why'd
you do that he goes well would I rather
stink up an Uber with an Uber driver in
there or just go into the subway that
already smells like [__] and then nobody
will know the difference be honest how
much is that